foreign
[Music]
to give her tissue Mira we made
children's books maybe it's better to
prepare them life will inevitably Crush
their hopes and dreams
[Music]
you know I'm just wearing my dead
boyfriend's shirt and texting his whole
number
Rob wanted to make sure you got one of
these I have a phone you have a personal
phone this is a work phone
I miss you so much there's a making me
inside of me
do you have a question for me yes Mr do
you really believe in all these things
you sing you obviously know nothing
about it what
[Music]
since you passed and I still can't
believe it who is sending me these texts
every morning I open my eyes hoping I'll
still see you I must have the
boyfriend's number that's super sad like
they're nice there is nothing wrong with
putting yourself back out there again
you go in there get the D you make it
sound like I have a vitamin deficiency
yeah you kind of do you have a vitamin D
deficiency because when the sun comes up
maybe we just take it a little slower
they're never gonna hold me down I think
I might have feelings for someone I've
never met these sticks are receiving are
saying something it might be crazy but
love doesn't always follow the rules
I'm wearing it to the Opera tonight I'm
gonna go see her these are from a
literal stranger I just need to put a
face to these texts
[Music]
I know you I'm not sure oh my God you
just got yourself a date the normal way
she thinks I am interesting you need to
tell her the truth you should have said
something to her right away
again
I was looking forward to this I just
felt like I knew you or something do you
think I could fall in love with someone
just through their words I think you're
very cute
the more I get to know her the better I
like her
[Music]
he's like this
don't just happen love is a plan for
each and every one of us
hi this is Celine Dion sure and I'm
Mariah Carey love comes to those who
believe it and this is really me oh my
gosh hi
[Music]
thank you